I'm Russell Altman and I'm an assistant scoutmaster with truth number 555 in
Ridge Springs, South Carolina.
This edition of the scout master podcast is sponsored by backers like us.
And now the old scout master.
Hey, I saw a really impressive pioneering project the other day,
something I've never seen before.
These scouts pioneered together somehow a cannon.
a cannon, believe it or not, a working cannon.
It was really something. as a matter of fact,
it was big enough so that you could actually shoot a scout out of the cannon.
Now I know what you're thinking. right, This could not be safe.
I thought the same thing, but it was okay.
They couldn't find a scout of the right caliber anyway.
Hey, this is podcast number 255..
Hey, well, welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Greene.
Let's see. let's take a look at the mailbag. Shall we?
Carson Boone wrote in to ask: where do I find the songs used on the podcast?
Well, Carson, I make that as difficult as possible sometimes, don't I?
But if you look at the archive page for the podcast,
you'll see that there's a link to the podcast.
there's a widget there that has a lot of the music that I use on it
And I am trying to get in the habit of making sure I include a link
to the music used on each podcast in the post that contains that podcast.
So I'll get better at it. but thanks for getting in touch, Carson.
We heard from Ken Greenberg, who's an assistant scout master with troop 30
in Bucks County, Pennsylvania, who asked this favor.
He said as a part of my ticket for Wood Badge,
I've been surveying troops in my district about their patrol practices
In an effort to broaden my responses. I was hoping you'd be willing
to circulate the survey. The survey is just one page long.
It's only 15 questions.
Scouts who want to participate can email me the completed survey
And I'll have the survey open until March 15th
And I would be willing to share the results of the survey with anyone who answers.
any help you can give me as appreciated.
Well, Ken, we'll do our best here.
So folks go to the post that contains this podcast on scoutmastercgcom.
There is a PDF version of Ken's survey linked on that post.
Go ahead, download it. His email address is on the PDF
And you can go ahead and complete the survey and email it right back to Ken.
Let's see On the blog. this week we had a post about a 10 scout, a 10 scout
No, a 10 point scout troop checkup
And just 10 questions that result in kind of non-metric answers.
We have the Journey to Excellence and other evaluation tools.
These are mostly metrics. These are mostly numbers:
How many scouts are in the troop, How often do they go camping?
What I did is came up with 10 non-metric questions,
Things that aren't metrics but would point to our success in communicating
and running the program.
I heard from several people about that post.
Randall Cox said these are good questions to be asking.
A troop who expects to be viable in five years should be asking them.
James Chaplin said the checklist is right in the mark.
I just asked most of these questions before your article was posted
with the troop that I am now scout master for.
They recruited me to fix their failing troop operation.
I cannot think that we were able to answer any of those questions
in the positive. but the real question will be:
is how we answer them in a year or less?
Well, this gives you something to work with, right?
So I'm glad that you're finding that helpful.
Bob M said: excellent questions, Very thought-provoking and eye-opening for me.
Thanks for the counsel. Thanks for getting in touch.
I'm glad they're useful to you.
Tim Georgie said: when I start to get complacent about how well I think
our troop is doing, I inevitably read something like this.
that blows that notion out of the water.
You've provided some really good thoughts on areas we can improve upon.
We all get a little complacent from time to time.
And those 10 questions in that post- it's the 10-point scout troop checkup
And it's on scoutmastercgcom- just published it last week.
These should well they at least- give you something to think about. right,
During our chat sessions this week, talk to several new people.
I know a lot of our frequent fliers checked in
And you've heard their names many times on the last few podcasts.
So what I'm going to do? I want to mention the folks who checked in
on the live chat for their first time.
Now, if you want to get in on one of the live chats-
we're going to do these mostly on weekday mornings.
You'll find an announcement about the live chat
on the Facebook feed or the Twitter feed,
So keep an eye on those.
When you see that we're going to be on a live chat, go ahead.
go to scoutmastercgcom, sign in and join us.
It's great fun,
And this week Jackie Reese from Santa Rosa, California.
He's on the district committee and he's an assistant scoutmaster.
Jackie checked in.
Matt Thompson from Eureka, Kansas, where he's a member of both PAC
and troop committees.
Marty Medovic from Wheeling, West Virginia, who's been
a scoutmaster for the last 10 years, was part of our chat,
as was Lawrence Ratner, who's an assistant scoutmaster
with troop 88, from Fairfield, Connecticut.
Paul Farley is in Peachtree Corners, Georgia,
just outside of Atlanta there with PAC 525
and Paul's a Weebelos Den Leader.
Merrick Fonsbeck is in Lehigh, Utah, with troop 581
and he's their advancement chair.
And Steve Cerudi from Oceanside, California,
who is working with his third Weebelos Den,
was also a part of our chat.
So, once again, watch the Facebook feed,
watch the Twitter feed, look for the live chats.
go to scoutmastercgcom, sign in and join us.
If you're a regular reader and listener
and the resources we've created have helped you,
I'm going to ask you to return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing everything that we do-
the posts, the podcast and all of those other resources-
and making them accessible for everyone.
So it's an easy thing to do. go to scoutmastercgcom,
look for the support link up at the top of the page,
and there are several levels of support
that you can take advantage of,
and some of them entitle you to premiums
like autograph copies of my books.
Now I want to take a moment to personally thank
George Morrison, Jill Blantz, Randy Farmer,
Robert Hedrick and Josh Nepper,
who have become backers since last week's podcast.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you during our next podcast.
I can't tell you how much this support means to me,
and I don't like talking about money anymore than you do,
but that's what it takes to keep things up and running,
so I really, really appreciate your help everyone.
Hey, I want to add that beginning tomorrow, Tuesday,
I'm going to have a series of five posts
that are directed at Cub Leaders
Now. I spent several years as a Cub Master
and Assistant Cub Master, a Den Leader for Wolf
Bearer and Weebel as Den's,
so I have some experience with the Cub Program
and I want to offer some observations
that I hope will help you out
if you're working with Cubs
Now. I'm not going to be talking about
specific program schedules
and specific things about advancement
or craft ideas or anything like that.
There are lots of people out there
who have wonderful resources on those things.
What I'm going to concentrate on
are some of the things that helped me
when I was working with Cubs
and that I hope will help you.
So that'll begin tomorrow, Tuesday,
and go for five days,
and I would be really interested to hear your comments
on that series of posts.
So go to scoutmastercgcom
and check them out.
Well, this week, in Scout Mastership-
in seven minutes or less-
we're going to talk about High Adventure a little bit,
and then we've got some email questions to answer,
and that's going to constitute the remainder
of this particular podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes
or less.
Well, here's the message:
You must go,
You have to go right.
How are your plans for your next
High Adventure trip coming along?
You know that it's a great experience.
You know that it'll do more for your Scouts
than you can imagine,
but most of us, you know-
let's face facts- we don't get started, do we?
We think it's either too expensive
or we're doubt we're going to have the time,
or we lack the skills or confidence
to get the ball rolling.
The open secret, though, is that High Adventure
does not have to be
expensive or difficult
or complex, right.
Many troops and crews
make their own plans and offer
High Adventure experiences to their Scouts
on a regular basis.
We want to talk for a moment
about putting together a High Adventure program
suited to the ambitions
and abilities of your Scouts.
It's not as expensive or difficult
or time-consuming as you might think.
For the past 10 years,
we have alternated between
going for two years
up to Algonquin Park
in Ontario, Canada,
for a canoe trip
and going over to
Condersteg International Scout Center
for the third year.
We started the canoe trips 10 years ago.
We started doing the rotation through
Condersteg four years ago.
I also want to mention that
I would love to take you and your Scouts
to Condersteg in the summer of 2016..
I have some details
about how that's going to happen
over on ScoutmasterCGcom,
so make sure to check that out
and if you're interested,
let's get going. we'll get that put together
so that in 2016,
you can take a group of Scouts to Condersteg
in Switzerland. but
that's a pretty big trip.
It's going to cost some money.
These other trips that you can do,
these other high-adventure experiences
that you can make happen for your Scouts,
are not too expensive.
A perfectly great high-adventure trip
doesn't have to cost a lot of money.
We've done backpacking trips
of five days for less than $200..
You know, you can
set up the trip
with the ability of your Scouts
to participate in it. financially.
It'll work.
I can tell you that it will work.
We're going to talk about specifically
how that will work just a little later on.
The other objection is:
a lot of people say I really don't have the time
to put into a high-adventure trip.
No, you don't
if it's going to be two weeks long.
but there's nothing
that says a high-adventure trip
has to be
any certain number of days.
A high-adventure trip can be
three or four days,
It can be 14 days, It can be 21 days,
It can be five or six days.
You make up your mind
how much time you're going to have to spend.
I know vacation days are precious
when you have a family and you can't
invest them all in a Scout trip.
So, three days of vacation:
If you leave on a Wednesday, that means
you've got Wednesday, Thursday and Friday.
Then you have Saturday and Sunday.
back at work on Monday.
So you have a five-day trip that you can do.
Now if you're the parent of a Scout
and you want to do high-adventure with them.
you've got a limited window of opportunity
to be able to do that,
So you've got to make it happen
Now. maybe you think you don't have
the skills or confidence
to set up a trip like this
and to make sure that it's safe
and that it's going to work for your Scouts.
Well, most people don't have the skills
and confidence to do anything like this.
One of the best parts of the high-adventure trip
are the months that you spend
planning and learning and practicing skills.
I've seen a lot of back-country groups
who were really
experienced and ill-prepared,
Yet they managed to survive.
If not really enjoy themselves,
they did manage to survive.
You're going to be more prepared
than most of them, alright,
So select a modest goal
and be the spark plug
to make this happen and start planning now.
You'll do more for your troop
and the patrols and the Scouts
than you can imagine.
Don't make it too complicated.
Make it accessible, financially and time-wise,
and just start
making it happen.
Everybody knows about Fillmont
and Seabase and Northern Tier.
There are three most familiar
high-adventure bases
and there are dozens of
council-based programs too.
Thousands of Scouts participate
and enjoy those big three
high-adventure bases every year,
and I guess we need to add the summit in,
so we'll call it Big Four,
and I have colleagues in Scouting
who recommend all of these places highly.
but at the other end of the spectrum
are the ones that you can actually get to
and your Scouts can actually get to
and you can explore
a little less known territory that way.
So my rationale for
building your whole high-adventure program,
other than what we've already spoken about,
is that you know most of the national
programs. as wonderful as they are,
they're pre-prand preset
programs that involve a minimum amount
of flexibility. The dates,
the activities involved, the equipment
and the routes are pretty well set up.
There's also a good deal of competition
to get in to some of those places.
I mean, it's a two or three-year
process just to be able to
get to a lot of them.
But where you go and what you do
for your high-adventure program
is limited. It's just about anywhere
and you can do just about anything.
Maybe it's a week of backpacking
or canoeing or touring or cycling
or boating, You know, whatever
your Scouts think, that
would be great. fun
is something that you can put together
and you don't need to travel very far,
You don't need to get on a plane,
You don't need to drive eight hours.
Look what's in a two or three-hour
circle of where you are right now.
I'll bet there's a state
within that two or three-hour circle
with a great trail where you can spend
three or four days backpacking.
I'll bet within that two or three-hour
circle there is a council-based
high-adventure program at a scout camp
somewhere. I'll bet there's a river
that you can do a three or four
day canoe trip on.
So once you've got an idea,
a basic idea of what's accessible,
somebody has to say:
this looks like a great place, so let's
go and then show everybody
that it's actually possible.
Now this can be a little more challenging than you think,
especially with the first time
out of the box on a trip like this.
It may be difficult to get everybody
to think that it's even possible.
but you can do it. It needs a little vision
and a little leadership. Troop-based trips
are going to be full of details.
Preparation may take as many hours
as the trip itself. but, like I said,
that's half the fun. The work
you put into planning pays big dividends.
Research the activity
location thoroughly and plan
the preparations to complete
that adventure safely. So you're going
to make a commitment to
training and skill development-
The leaders, advisors and participants
are going to need to commit
time to training and learning
the applicable skills to safely
carry out the trip plan, And that's
going to mean making sure that
you're up to date on things like CPR
and wilderness first aid.
Although those things wouldn't
necessarily be strictly required in a
program that you create yourself,
I highly recommend them. You want to check
out your weather skills? If it's a backpacking
trip, you want to hone your backpacking skills.
If it's a canoe trip, you need to hone
those skills, but you need to make
a commitment to carrying that out. And then
you also need to consider the financial
end of it. Who's going to be collecting
money? You know how much is all this
going to cost, But it's very,
very doable. There's lots of resources
at ScoutmasterCGcom about
planning, And I lay out in a series
of posts exactly how
we do our high adventure
canoe trips, And that should give you some
information that you can apply to just
about any high adventure trip.
So we know how all of this begins.
Somebody says
this is going to be possible.
These are our alternatives.
Let's choose one and let's get going,
And that's someone minus. well be you,
because every Scout should have
a high adventure experience. They should
have the advantage of being able to do that
and you're the person who can make it
happen.
I had this
email from Nick
Paulson,
who said: I am in my
third year as
Scoutmaster and I'm very happy with
what we're doing.
The Scouts and I regularly plan
activities and outings
And I'm very happy with
what we're doing. The Scouts
and I regularly plan activities
and outings And I'm very happy
with what we're doing.
The Scouts and I regularly plan activities
and outings, but I'm constantly
battling things like sports schedules.
They plan a camp out, for
example. Parents are notified
and we're signing guys up until
the Sunday, before the outing
on Friday. then all of a sudden,
motocross races appear
and football and baseball
and basketball games appear and we
end up losing several of our Scouts.
Then the others find out their friends aren't going
and they decide not to go.
One Scout is going and then
that's hardly worth making it happen.
It's really frustrating
and I don't have a clue about how to combat it,
combat this. Do you have any suggestions?
Well, Nick, you know,
I think everybody understands exactly
what you're saying. I know that we've had that problem
as well And I wish
I knew one easy
bit of advice to give you about how to fix it.
but let me talk about some alternatives.
You know, it may be that trying
to schedule one troop
camping trip every month
and expecting a critical mass of Scouts
to get to it,
that time may be past. I really don't
know, but that's kind of the feeling that I
have sometimes. Logically,
there are two alternatives to this problem.
we can either alter the behavior of the
Scouts and their families or we can alter
the schedule of the program. I think
we need to probably end up doing a little bit of both.
Just trying to alter
everyone's behavior
is not going to be a winning option.
I think, right that if you
announce far enough ahead of time
what the dates are going to be
and parents understand that these are important-
and having a critical mass of Scouts
going along is important
not only just, you know, to the
viability of the trip logistically,
but for Scouting to happen we need, like this,
critical mass. You would hope
that they would understand that. So
if they don't, maybe we need to explain
what we're doing a little bit better. Maybe
we need to help them value what's happening
better, because I know that the
sports schedules they're not made the week
before they're out for a long time.
so families, a lot of times,
you know, they just need to kind of step
up and coordinate those calendars better
and we need to explain that to them and help
them out by making our expectations
very clear. But you know,
those calendars, those family calendars,
are very, very complex
and nine times out of ten
our Scouts aren't making
the decision whether or not they're going to
go on a camping trip based
on whether or not they want to go.
it's pretty much dictated by a schedule.
as you know, one guy doesn't go
and his friends all bail out and that's kind of discouraging.
but the demands
of a Scout
age boys schedule are pretty stunning
sometimes and
most of the other activities that they're involved
in compel their attendance.
you have to be at the game,
you have to be at the practice, you have to be
at the play rehearsal, you
must do these things,
which I think you know is kind of unfair
to our youth
because if we want them involved in lots
of different things we all have to give
and take a little bit. I have found
that a lot of times if a Scout
will go and talk to a coach or the director
of a player or something, explain what they're doing,
say I really I have
some responsibility to my Scout troop
and I need to go
on this particular camping trip and that means
I'm going to miss a practice or a game
or something that the coach or the play director
or whatever is perfectly fine
with that. just getting the Scouts
to the point where they're going to go and talk
to these people is what it can
be- a bit of a challenge. So what about
our schedule? how about looking at our schedule?
I think altering our schedule
can be
maybe part of the part of the answer.
I know what we're looking at. right now
we have one trip every quarter. you know
that for years have
been very, very well attended-
and then we usually have two trips
every quarter that are
not so well attended. we don't really
end up seeing a whole lot of Scouts out
on those. so we're really considering
changing the schedule so that
we have only one quarterly
outing where we're expecting the entire
troop to show up, and then we
what we'd like to see happen the other two months
is have patrols, plan
an individual outing or activity. that's
going to better fit the schedule.
if you try to get 30 people to one
thing every month,
that is a big challenge nowadays
if you try to get eight
and they can decide on the date.
that makes it a little bit simpler.
now we get reasonably good attendance
at our weekly troop meetings, but I'd
like to create even more opportunities
for participation. so we're
looking at having
open activity days
every Saturday. there wouldn't
these wouldn't necessarily be overnight, it's just
a few hours to get together for skill development
and fun, kind of like
a sports team schedule,
kind of like a practice schedule.
we're fortunate in that our meeting place
has plenty of outdoor space
and we can walk to a local park
with even more space.
so this may be a very good
possibility for us. but in the
end the situation you describe
isn't uncommon. it's not necessarily
that anybody's doing anything wrong.
we just need to look
at what's going on and see if we can
innovate a solution
and catch up with the way Scouts lives
are ordered now, because what
worked a decade or two ago
isn't going to cut it for everybody,
and I'd be very interested to hear everyone's thoughts
on this particular thing because I know
it's a pretty common problem.
I heard from Kelly Tansy
who wrote in to say
I wrote you a couple months ago about my frustrations
with the troop my son joined
after we moved to a small town.
I listened to a podcast after sending
that email and your answer to me was
basically that as a parent
I was not really in a position
to affect change in the way
that the troop operates. my options
were to stick it out with this troop and follow
the lead of the scout master in the committee
or switch my son to another troop.
well, a few weeks
after writing you, I attended
a district training about chartered organization
representatives and I had
a heart to heart with our committee chair.
she decided to switch roles
to the chartered organization representative
and I've become the committee chair.
I've been doing lots of
reading and listening and following your example
of going to the resources for
information. I've been
familiarizing myself with the official BSA
troop committee guidebook.
I am glad to be
in the position to take action and not
just be a concerned parent anymore.
last night
was our first committee meeting
with me as the chair
and the first troop meeting where our senior
patrol leader was actually running the
meeting. it was really a great night
for our troop. at the committee
meeting, parents stepped up to fill all
the committee positions but one.
I kept to the agenda I prepared and there was
no adult bickering. I
felt pretty good about it. my first
goals were to have an agenda for the meeting,
to fill in the positions and
get at least one camp out on the schedule
next month. and I've got to
say, except for one empty
position, mission accomplished.
well, good for you, Kelly. that's pretty encouraging
story there.
Kelly goes on to say even more exciting
was watching our new senior patrol leader
and assistant senior patrol leader pretty much
lead their own meeting. they weren't
really prepped to do so beforehand
and they were kind of winging it, but they did a great
job. it was so awesome
to see. after the troop meeting.
we happen to be having a border review
for both of them and we adults
must have congratulated them several times
on their excellent job. the senior patrol
leader has a patrol leaders council
meeting next week, the first
one I think this troop has ever had,
and he really seems to be on the ball.
we all have much to learn,
but it's just so exciting to see the
troop going in the right direction. so
what's your advice for the committee chair
of a troop in transition?
thanks again for all the information you've
gathered in one place and for the podcast.
I cannot begin to tell you how helpful it
is. well, wow,
Kelly, you did it. good for
you. since you asked for
some advice, I'll give you a little bit. my
advice is to keep on doing what you're doing.
sounds like you have things rolling in the right
direction. keep asking questions,
look at those resources and just
continue to make things happen.
now I will add one thing
that may not be readily apparent,
and that is that scouts have a lot
of what it takes to run the show already.
as you described, they'll step right up
and they'll start doing things. where they're
going to need some help is getting the
schedule worked out and developing the habits
of planning and preparing their
activities. there are three distinct
things: planning, preparing
and doing. okay, I've
talked to scouts about this all the time.
planning is easy. preparation
is usually where things get a little
dicey, so you'll want to be
working with the scout master and the senior
patrol leader, helping scouts learn
to prepare by first making sure
there's a distinction between
planning and preparing. scouts
plan at the speed of thought,
right, they can sit down
and come up with a list of things
that they want to do, they can
put them on a calendar and they think,
well, we're done until that
thing rolls around. what they miss
is preparing what they have planned.
so we want to help them
work their way through exactly what needs
to be prepared, and they'll catch on
pretty quickly. so what I mean
specifically is actually
working through what they've planned,
with an eye to what they will need
to make whatever they've planned
happen, and rehearsing how
they're going to do that. they'll need to
think through how they
will also get
the scouts they are serving in their troop
and patrols prepared
for whatever it is they have
planned. what skills and knowledge do the
scouts need to carry out their
plan? what kind of gear will they need?
does everybody know how to use the gear?
there are lots and lots of questions
to be asked and answered.
I tell our scouts that planning is
10% of the effort,
preparing is 60% of the effort
and doing-
actually doing what you've planned-
is 30% of the effort, and this
kind of helps them visualize how important
the preparation stage is.
I have an article that describes
the components that I've mentioned here
and that I'll link to in a post that contains
this podcast. but once again,
good for you, Kelly.
thanks for getting involved in making
things happen for your scouts.
if you have a question,
you can get in touch with me and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
thanks so much for listening to this
255th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
it's easy to keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates
by email.
there are 4000 or so mobile
scouts who have the scoutmastercg app
on their mobile devices
and stay in touch. that way
you can get the app
on google play
or in the itunes app store.
you can put that on your tablet or your cell phone.
you can experience the wonders
that constitute scoutmastercgcom
in the vast panorama
of social media.
you can join the 7900 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1200
tweeters on twitter.
pin the poultrytutenous pictures proffered publicly
with 1900 other prolific
pinners on pinterest.
go and watch us on youtube
and you can join the 400 odd folks
in the sleepy little corner of the internet
called google plus.
now, if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better, if you know interest in pinterest,
you don't put the? u in youtube.
if you're a minus when it comes to google plus,
well, that's alright. bunkie,
zoom in to the late 90s and fire off an email.
you can send me an email
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c-l-a-r-k-e
at scoutmastercgcom.
I must hasten to add
that the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official
publications of anybody,
nope.
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the boy scouts of america,
or any other scouting organization
for that matter. it's just me
here with a microphone,
trying to land a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here is our founder, sir robert bedan. pal,
sir robert.
good luck to you and good camping,
sir, until next time, everyone.